but first to some breaking news from the
u.s where former president donald
trump's longtime ally steve bannon has
surrendered to federal authorities
bannon is facing charges for refusing to
cooperate with the congressional
investigation into the january 6 attack
on the u.s capitol let's bring in paddy
culhane who's following developments for
us in washington d.c paris
bannon's indictment on contempt charges
a few days ago sent shockwaves to
washington and now he's turned himself
in
he has he's turned himself into the fbi
field office he'll go before a federal
magistrate in a couple of hours these
are two misdemeanor charges so likely
he'll just be released on his own uh to
face charges later this is very rare the
justice department very rarely goes
after people for contempt of congress
but steve bannon is facing two charges
one for not showing up to an interview
one for not providing documents to the
congress that is investigating that
january 6th insurrection now bannon was
key to this committee's findings because
he was in the room with all of president
former president trump's uh advisers
in the days before the january 6th
insurrection he will know what was said
what was talked about he went on his own
radio show the day before and said all
hell was going to break loose in
washington so investigators want to know
what exactly did he mean by that now he
is claiming executive privilege most
legal experts say that is not going to
hold up for a couple of reasons one he
wasn't working for the president at the
time he hadn't for about three years uh
and also uh that that the president is
no longer the president and president
biden has said there will not be
executive privilege in this case but
what i think he's hoping to do is delay
it because republicans hope to take over
the house in 2022 they could kill the
investigation it also seems pretty clear
that he's trying to score political
points with the pro-trump crowd because
he could have simply showed up and
played the fifth and said i can't talk
because i'm
the fifth amendment says i don't have to
incriminate myself right uh but trump
has sent a message he wants all of his
people to simply refuse to cooperate uh
that said the committee is hoping this
also sends a message to all of the other
people who they've subpoenaed who
haven't shown up yet because bannon has
the means to fight this he's a very
wealthy man other people in trump's
orbit do not have those resources so
we'll see how this plays out as soon as
he can i was going to ask you what
what's likely to happen next i mean he's
turned himself into the fbi what's the
likelihood that he will actually appear
before the house committee investigating
the january 6 attack
incredibly unlikely this is going to
take a while to work its way through the
court system uh so he's going to show up
before the magistrate today he's going
to be asked some questions told what his
rights are he'll
most likely plead not guilty and be
released uh to go home as this works its
way again these are misdemeanor counts
so the maximum penalty would be up to a
year in jail and a thousand dollar fine
so this obviously he's going to go to
trial if he's found guilty of contempt
let's say he's given probation or given
some jail time the committee can try to
subpoena him again they could go through
this whole process again but they can't
actually make him show up they can hold
him in contempt but they can't actually
make him show up and they certainly
can't make him testify because again the
fifth amendment he can simply say i
refuse to answer on the grounds that i
might incriminate myself all right patty
thank you very much for that patty cohen
live for us in washington
are you